well elon's another cat so I know you've
thought so you have this piece of Mars
right so he's trying to get to Mars now
right but Joe have you ever thought like
uh which one of his 10 kids I mean Who's
Gonna Leave Behind like to do that goes
to Mars I think he's like he wants to go
to Mars he said he wants to die on Mars
by the time he is able to do this he'll
probably be fully grown adults maybe go
visit him they go and come with him
apparently the idea is to be able to
come back which is just like okay I saw
the Martian
did you like that yeah I love him Mars
Andy Weir is he UCSD he didn't graduate
from UCSD but he wrote it um yeah but
I mean
it is possible that one day we will have
the technology to colonize other planets
right do we have that do we have the
reason to do it Joe what is the reason
like this isn't sometimes the reason
just to be able to do it or maybe to
ensure that human race survives and if
there's some sort of a natural disaster
on Earth do you know what Nixon road on
the plaque that went to the moon on
Apollo 11 no what said we came in peace
For All Mankind it's right
there was a war against the Soviets it
was part of the Cold War as a war
propaganda and it was important it did a
lot for science guess what we haven't
been back to the Moon in 50 years right
so if it was so important for peace and
for technology why are we in the mag
okay so to say what we did it's the
Edmund Hillary thing you know climbing
Everest because it's there right but um
but Elon has said the following he has
said I want to go to Mars so that
humankind becomes interplanetary then
you ask I love to keep asking why
questions right because they're so
annoying like your kids keep asking you
why you know what the ultimate answer is
because I freaking said so go to sleep
right so with with him I keep asking why
why do you want to send people tomorrow
why should a humankind be interplanetary
so that the flame of Consciousness uh
never gets extinguished why
um why can't you go under the ocean why
can't you build bubble cities why can't
you build floating clouds the Earth gets
destroyed okay but why why what why why
why continue with Humanity not just
humans and he's talking about human
consciousness which could also mean like
AI stuff or whatever but but here's my
here's my bigger point you've you had
Ryan holiday on recently he's got this
Memento Mori coins right momentum
already means remember you're gonna die
allegedly Roman emperors would have some
quarters and walking next to them so
they wouldn't have too much hubris they
would say remember you're mortal you're
gonna die
um that was done to motivate them to
suck the marrow out of life while you're
alive right so my question at some level
is well is that true only of individuals
or like could it be true of a
civilization as a whole could it be true
that like hey wait we shouldn't be
dedicating all this effort and I think
it's I wouldn't say it's as as unlikely
as life you know having iPhones on
proximus and glory be but but I'd say
it's pretty likely that we're going to
do that in the next hundred years to
have colonized Mars it's incredibly
difficult from a technological
standpoint from a biological standpoint
a psychological standpoint the raw
material there's tremendous number of
reasons technology progresses the way it
has since 1800 the way I mean it's on
world the world's unrecognizable you
could conceivably say that if it
continues in the same direction we don't
blow ourselves up we may very well have
the ability to do something like that so
there's and if you say why yeah well why
not well why not is always fascinating
right because it's interesting because
people want to do it because it would be
significant to have human life living on
a terraformed Mars to put it on our
resume maybe we could use Mars as like a
test like how to recharge an atmosphere
if we it up right but isn't it
better just not to it up yeah it is
not it is better not to it up but
it's also interesting like if why go to
the Moon why why send satellites out
there why why look at stars why all
those things it's part of this human
desire to constantly innovate and move
forward but I I question the Moore's Law
kind of compatibility and actually you
talked about this in Michio Kaku and and
he was in his new book about Quantum
Supremacy which is this this kind of
faith in these exponential curves and
exponential curves are really tricky
ammos mofo is because you know they
sneak up on you for a long time like
something like this right well one of
the things that they do after they do
this is they do this
they come down right you've heard of
peak oil and stuff like that right
there's only a finite amount of oil
because there's only a finite amount of
pre-carbon in this fossil fuels
Etc but it's it's worse than that as we
get more and more
um uh kind of technologically capable we
get better and better at keeping the
Ponzi scheme going in a sense like the
or grade of of gold used to be like in
California 1849 right they would stumble
upon a huge brick Rock of gold that
never happens anymore that the amount of
gold per ton is like a gram per ton it's
incredibly small and it's going down all
these things are going down there all
these diminishing s-curves they call
them they start off really high and so
you get the go go 90 you know and then
it goes drops off to zero there's no
saying that that might not also happen
for both extraction and resources that
you need to build a colony on Mars fuel
rocket Parts Etc but also for the you
know the coming Ai and Computing
revolution in other words Moore's Law is
saturating for a very interesting reason
it's not that it's not that the the
speed of the computers is still doubling
but the amount do you care about the
speed of your computer no you care about
what I can do with it right right how
fast is the web page load up right well
so you can have the fastest computer but
it's it's loading really slowly because
there's so many other people that want
to take advantage and use that same
resource it's very highly in demand
resource that will happen with Quantum
Computing too it's already happening
with classical supercomputers in other
words their speed is going up but the
number of floating Point operations they
do is saturating because so many people
want to use them because they're so good
they're victim of their own success in a
certain sense same thing can happen with
mineral so the question is do we get
there and if not well what what would
that mean would we have like a
civilization existential crisis I don't
know I I really don't know but even all
the things you just stated isn't that
just within our technological
limitations as of today and our
understanding of how to put together
computers our understanding of what
technology can consist of in terms of
minerals in terms of like stable
materials
yes or no I mean there's but like I said
there's only so much carbon in the earth
there's only so many pre-biologic
fossils it can it be recycled can we
find new ways to use it can't we figure
out a way to sure yeah we can but the
question is these different things have
to overlap